the health benefits of certain mushrooms
are quite mind-blowing so today I'm
going to take some of the confusions
that people have about mushrooms and
just make it really really simple so if
you have a very specific health problem
you'll know exactly what to take now I'm
going to primarily focus on four
different types of mushrooms okay
but they're in the family of fungus okay
or fungi and fungi is very interesting
because there's more related DNA wise to
a fungus than there is to plants in
other words like plants have
photosynthesis so they actually breathe
in CO2 and they make oxygen well
mushrooms which is a type of fungus
don't do that they breathe in oxygen and
release CO2 very similar to humans they
actually share 50 of their DNA which
basically means they have certain
blueprints that make certain chemicals
that we can use for the benefit of our
own health fungi is the largest and
oldest organism on planet Earth in fact
in just one handful of soil from the
forest you have literally 26 miles
of a certain type of fungi called
mycelium so there is a tremendous amount
of fungus working in the soil with the
roots of plants exchanging different
nutrients to make sure that plant has
the nutrients that it needs and getting
certain sugars from the plants as their
food and so really it's a fungus that
mobilize the minerals in the soil and so
without this fungus the plant really has
a hard time getting nutrition fungus is
also responsible for breaking things
down like organic matter trees wood
leaves Etc so they are the great
recyclers but today we're going to talk
about four key mushrooms that you need
to know about and I want to make it
really really simple for you the first
one is the reishi mushroom okay this
mushroom could be thought of as a
natural Xanax now of course I'm not
promoting medication but this is the
natural version without the side effects
and what does that medication do it's
purported to help you with anxiety and
helping you calm down therefore it's
also good for sleep if you want to
increase your tolerance to stress if you
want to counter stress and cortisol this
mushroom might be a good one to add to
your diet the next one is lion's mane
okay
because it looks like a lion's mane this
one could be considered like a natural
Adderall but without the side effects
what is that drug well it's used for
people with cognitive problems attention
deficit issues and a lot of college
students take it to increase their uh
their learning abilities because it kind
of speeds up the central nervous system
to a certain degree of course it has a
lot of side effects but lion's mane is
specifically good for cognitive function
improving Focus concentration
memory a lot of people take it as a
coffee replacement in the morning but it
has some really interesting benefits in
repairing and regenerating nerve tissue
in myelin sheath around the nerve it has
something called the neurotrophic factor
which just helps support nerve growth in
general specifically in the area of the
brain called a hippocampus which is
involved with cognitive function to a
certain grade this mushroom also has
been known to increase something called
bdnf brain derived neurotrophic Factor
that's kind of like Miracle Grow but for
your brain so it helps the nerves grow
so when you think about lion's mane
think cognitive improvements and
anything related to a breakdown in your
brain like neurodegenerative conditions
like Alzheimer's Parkinson's
dementia then we have the shiitake
mushroom that mushroom is good for blood
pressure it's really beneficial for your
gut microbiome a good portion of our
immune system is in the gut and shiitake
mushroom can actually increase the
killer T cells which are responsible for
killing viruses and the last one which I
think is the most interesting is the
turkey tail mushroom this one has been
researched the most when you think of
turkey tail you want to think of
anti-cancer properties but as far as
turkey tail goes I would recommend
anyone who has cancer to start taking it
immediately it has a non-specific immune
modulating action which basically
strengthen the immune system overall so
if someone is on chemo or radiation
uh turkey tail is great to take against
cancer the white blood cells actually
eat
certain compounds in this mushroom like
beta-glucans and consume it carry it
into the lymphatic system to help cause
the cancer cell to commit suicide that's
called apoptosis a normal cell would
basically kill itself as a kind of a
greater good for the body but a cancer
cell basically lives forever now turkey
tail also reduces inflammation in your
gut which is also related to your immune
system as well because if you think
about cancer cancer tends to spread into
areas of inflammation all right so Rishi
is good as a natural Xanax for calming
down the flatter fight mechanism or
cortisol then we have lion's mane which
is everything to do with cognitive
function helping you concentrate helping
you focus and we have shiitake which is
three things cholesterol blood pressure
and your immune system and then we have
turkey tail which it has a potent
anti-cancer effect all right so I hope I
gave you some clarity on what these
mushrooms are good for and so the next
time you have a certain problem you'll
know exactly what mushroom to take or
eat since I mentioned Cancer and a good
remedy for that if you have not seen
this video on cancer it would be very
very smart to watch it and I put that
video up right here